j'ai beaucoup de réactions en internat
force ouvrière depuis sa désignation au
cabinet de monsieur soubie surtout pour
les missions qui vont être les siennes
qui s'inscrivent quand même dans une
logique d'accompagner aussi des plans de
restructuration ici patronaux et au
niveau des entreprises donc il ya une
vraie colère une vraie grogne interne à
force ouvrière au niveau des militants
et qui me disent également que puisque
jean claude mailly s'était auto-désigné
oc européen avant de partir il ya une
incompatibilité entre un tel choix
professionnel qui lui appartient c'est
un homme libre et le fait de garder un
mandat à force ouvrière
donc c'était facile cet automne et il
s'est auto-désignée au mandat au cse
européen mois avant que je sois
secrétaire général c'est assez
incompatibles eu égard à ces missions
aujourd'hui et au fait de cette de
désignation sur le co2 mais je pense
qu'il fera un choix envoyer ou non moi
je ne ferais rien je ne ferai rien jean
claude mailly fera en l'occurrence qu'il
veut mais en l'occurrence il faut non à
north bay excusez moi mais jean claude
mailly est sorti de l'organisation en
disant je n'aurai ni mandat est faux et
vous n'entendrez plus parler de moi je
constate qu'il s'auto désignent sur un
mandat est faux et excusez moi mais
j'aimerais bien qu'on arrête de parler
de lui